we just saw the arrival of George and
Amal Clooney I have to say there was a
little bit of a gasp when we saw a mall
in this gorgeous mustard yellow dress
with a perfectly matching matched hat I
already want to know whose dress is that
them all but that's not the main
question of the day and she's a
fashionista though she looks dapper too
yes but what have you ever seen her look
bad
never and there are the beckham's
Victoria and David Beckham also arriving
yes they know they're good friends of
Harry's yes Mark Phillips meanwhile is
outside of st. George's Chapel looking
ahead to the bride Megan markle's
arrival mark good morning good morning
well we've already seen just what kind
of a different wedding this is the
guests you just mentioned coming in as
well very different form where you tend
to see at events like this over the
years and I really think it might be
time just to talk a little bit about the
influence that Megan marca will have on
this royal family I think she may be the
freshest breath of air to blow through
it since Diana quite frankly Diana when
she joined the family young though she
was an aristocrat though she was a
function perhaps of the breakdown of her
relationship with Prince Charles at the
time became a terrific reforming
influence in the family with all the
causes she adopted aid aids land mines
that kind of thing her involvement as a
mother with her young son something we
hadn't seen amongst Royals before and of
course the public reaction when she when
she died that night in Paris and for the
several weeks thereafter really changed
the nature of the Royals from that point
on they became not quite touchy-feely
but much more accessible emotionally
particularly in terms of her two sons
William and Harry in Megan Marcos
someone who's coming in who's already
mature who already has issues with which
she associates herself who has had a
career who is her own woman and Megan
Marco even before this wedding had
become the star of the family a Perry
was the most popular royal as all the
polls say
it's megan's mark Megan Marvel's picture
on magazines that that sells them around
this country and in fact around the
world and I think she's she is going to
be in many ways the face of this family
going forward they have the same
hairdresser she introduced them
all right mark thank you very much